what is happening reject nation I'm Greg
Alva today I'm going to watch the final
trailer for Marvel's the defenders I'm
going to be out of town in Colorado the
weekend the defenders comes out I'm
going to be taking a trip so I won't be
able to watch the defenders the weekend
it comes out but when I get back on the
22nd of minutes are binge-watching them
just a heads up reviews are going to be
late and heads up patron the day
shout-out James Dagon's today - are you
still takes a lot of energy to some of
my cheek what you ate quite a great team
now looking for super things they do you
keep on telling yourself
[Music]
that cousin hope you saved us today for
war for New Yorkers here everything
whoa not yeah so get your [ __ ] together
we have time to grab a drink
[Music]
we'll do something crazy
[Music]
anybody know
I can see you must clean up volunteers I
promise you it's temporary if I can help
it whoa that's cool what the [ __ ] well I
did stop always at the end of the
trailer
thanks Lenny moving in just there okay I
guess that was the end of the trailer I
don't know how they're going to be
approaching the tone of this specific
series they have of the defenders of
bringing them all together but it does
seem Avengers reminiscent the four shows
are crossing over here the work to
describe them I wouldn't call them fun
you know like they're fun in their own
way but the tone and vibe is a lot more
serious and dark and gritty the tone
that I've seen a lot of these trailers
like the rock music seems to go well
with it they show a lot of dance or a
lot of clips you know I've seen Danny
Rand getting made fun of is a delight I
feel like that might make his character
even better because he's the youngest
one has the most childish personality of
them all looking forward to the
chemistry of Luke Cage bagging on Danny
Rand a lot because I know they have
their comic book history I'm excited to
see if their chemistry and their
relationship grow I know some people
have released their episode 1 review of
the defenders the people that were able
to catch it at Comic Con or some people
who got like the first four episodes
released to them early as a press
training I'm not listening to any of
that I don't want to hear any of those
reviews until I watch the show myself
I'm excited for that restaurant bite I'm
wondering if that might be the first
time the four of them are fighting
together steak shows up Sigourney Weaver
shows up and they show a bunch of
henchmen show up and then the four that
have to work together and fight I'm
wondering if that's going to be the
first time they fight as a unit and you
get some cool hints of teamwork here you
know when Danny Rand is hiding behind
Luke cages there's a firing machine guns
at him and then once they're done firing
the machine gun steady rep pops out and
says knock them out and anyone who's
seen my videos before knows I'm not a
big fan of Finn Jones as Danny ran I
feel like in this specific show he's
probably going to fit in better I feel
like he will work better as part of an
ensemble piece as opposed to helming his
own show because the position he plays
as the younger guy the position he plays
here as the younger dude there seems
like the group will probably make fun of
at least Luke Cage the use of his powers
looks even cooler here that one shot
where it punches a bunch of
and they all go flying back the shot
where he breaks electro sword is really
cool me I'm just so excited for this I'm
half tempted to skip out on this trip to
Colorado and the wedding just so I can
watch the defenders I just don't want to
be in Colorado and going meet a bunch of
people
I just want to be on this trip and then
feel like I got to watch eight hours of
television over the weekend as well I
don't want watching the defenders to
feel like work I want it to feel
leisurely and then I'll do review still
and while the defender shows have been
showing us a lot of great hints at
teamwork camaraderie banter action
sequences them all fighting together I'm
really wondering what Sigourney Weaver
has up her sleeve for how she's gonna
get under their skin psychologically
because she has that one line in the
trailer where she's like they haven't
lost everything
not yet so I'm wondering what is she
going to do to make them all feel like
they lost everything
I imagine the last couple episodes are
going to be pretty intense ah so excited
for this show man my girlfriend got me
this shirt not a baby oh yeah picture of
the day shout out James Stegen hang out
a lot with you in the Google Hangouts we
do on patreon my friend how do I get to
see your face more often than ever in
the past four years we've had this
channel literally every time I did a
Google hangout he just sits at the
screen smoking a cigarette
I can't tell if he's entertained or not
or if he's having a good time does this
weird thing where he looks up and goes
like someone or something you're weird
James taegons are weird but I Love You
Man you had an interesting personality a
little bit on the darker side a little
bit on the edgy side but you're a cool
dude and I'm happy even in support of
the shop for so long and I was before
seeing those hangouts my friend anyway
guys keep a lookout for my review of the
defenders probably within a week after
its release do something subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell and check out our patreon if yeah
if you like the site patreon